good afternoon everyone i was just
getting ready to say
like we were at a board meeting uh we
will start the meeting shortly
we're going to do the 30-second
countdown so i had to remember that we
are not at a board meeting first of all
i want to thank everyone for being here
today
education is a very important topic
anything having to do with our children
what better backdrop we have than a
playground over here with children
playing i'd much rather have the cameras
directed on our children playing that at
me but that's not the way it is today
so i'd like to start out with a general
statement some remarks i will be taking
some
questions at the end but i do have to
remind everybody and i know that all of
our media folks are quite cognizant that
i must remain under open meeting law
parameters because of our agenda items
for tomorrow
so i'm linda cavazos i'm president of
the clark county school board i
represent district g
parkdale community center and with laura
dearing school very close next to us
this is my district i want to thank
parkdale community center
alex bernal
and the whole community for allowing me
to have this event here today
on january 6 2020 as the clark county
school board of trustees was concluding
their new officer elections
all of us saw alarming images of people
crashing through the gates
windows and doors of our nation's
capital
that day is now frequently referred to
as the january 6th insurrectionist
storming by domestic terrorists as i was
elected unanimously that morning by my
peers i never thought that as a school
board president
that my peers and i would be subjected
on a lesser scale to death threats
personal attacks on our families and
attempts to disrupt and shut down our
business meetings while still dealing
with a terrifying pandemic
board presidents across the nation have
had to deal with these attempted
disruptors while trying hard so hard to
hear the pleas and concerns of our
parents educators and the community
about mass
vaccines
transportation academic achievement
overcrowded classes
lack of services for our special needs
and ell students
substitute and driver shortages
educator shortages and resignations
toxic school climate and culture the
mental health of both our students and
educators and racism racism in our
schools
we have dealt with these challenges and
i'm proud to say that we have never had
a meeting shut down or failed to
complete our agendas we persevered but
much remains to be done regarding the
many issues that i just cited
our educators parents and community
deserve much credit for everything that
they did to get us through that really
difficult time so today why am i here
i wish to state to you that we face the
crisis
of a divided board of trustees
one that has struggled to come to
consensus on many important issues that
directly or indirectly affect our
students
educators and community
as a result of that division caused by
many factors i have no choice today but
to sadly but adamantly refute and deny
as truth many of the statements that
have been made in a letter released
publicly by trustee lola brooks in
support of an agenda item requesting
that i be removed as board president
the fact that this item was added very
soon after another agenda item
concerning the superintendent's
employment was quite frankly
disheartening
such a blatant display of retaliation
occurring
during a time when many students and our
own educators are stating and reporting
that intimidation and retaliation
openly exists in our district was very
distressing
this is something that can no longer be
ignored and it must be addressed
i for one will not look the other way
other statements made by two other
trustees who requested this item may be
addressed at tomorrow's board meeting
additional reference materials are being
added this afternoon if they have not
already been added to board docs
in closing as the board president i have
made mistakes i have not always gone in
the absolutely best direction but i have
tried my best to place the interest of
our students our educators and our
community first
because they are my constituents and
they elected me to re represent them
not the one single employee that the
trustees supervise
it is my wish that we can all go forward
find a path forward with civility
respect
and trust i'm sorry i'm trying to read
my scribbles here
we have to do that we have to find a
path forward in collaboration
because our kids are depending on us
i thank you again for being here today
and i will take a few questions that are
within the parameters of open meeting
law
thank you
reports from tiffany principles that you
have reached out to them directly in an
effort to out superintendent jar by
publicly humiliating him through no
confidence
um is this true no
it is not true
dave i believe that that has to look at
that we all consider that we have seven
different people and personalities on
this board we have to look more at our
commonalities and not our differences
and that we have to always always put
the needs of our children first
and that we we're going to have to find
a new way i i believe that communication
is the foundation of any kind of
effective governance and if we cannot
find that new way of communicating
it's going to be very difficult so
that's one way that i see that it's
going to look like go ahead
what do you think that would look like
i think that we would have to look i i
would want it to look like us coming
together to be able to discuss
differences
because i think right now we're at an
impasse so to speak where we just come
to like a brick wall so instead of
seeing like
maybe a transparent wall where you can
look at the other side and you can
consider their opinions i think that
right now we're at a point if you've
watched any of our board meetings and
again i just want to tell you if you
have netflix or amazon prime you should
maybe consider that on thursday nights
instead of the board meetings because
you have to you have to have a very
strong constitution to make it through
that and i say that lightly
but what i'm saying here is that if
you've watched any of the board meetings
you see that sometimes that impasse that
we come to
it's i feel that we are not coming
collaboratively together to look at the
other person's perspective and then to
find the best i want to say compromise
yes
hi victoria finally meet nice to meet
who have you us to discuss your title
they allege some um
victoria do you want to break that into
more than one
part is there is there a part that has
to do with bullying and then is it
connected up with micromanaging
okay
all right i understand that thank you
i think i want to respond to that by
first addressing the bullying part i am
a person that when we get a public
records request or we get something
that's a
inquiry about social media whether it's
twitter instagram you know whatever
i am never somebody that ever has to go
back and search through those emails or
the social media posts i have very
seldom ever had to
delete anything from a social media post
so i will adamantly and invite you all
to look at my social media
that there has been no bullying
now i'd like to address victoria if you
wish you know the other part of your
question
as far as was it micromanaging of social
media or
yes
um
[Music]
ah okay now i understand and thank you
for clarifying that
i will say that when i see a social
media post that directly refutes what
the superintendent and the board of
trustees have decided on
i will ask that person a question about
it
i have
not and again i invite you to look at my
social media
i am not somebody that gets into back
and forth and i don't see it as being
constructive i'm a former high school
teacher
i think most of you know that i'm a
therapist i used to be a family court
mediator and so
that's non-constructive to me so again i
invite you to look at that and i do deny
and refute that i will put social media
posts on there that i will answer
people's questions but you will not see
me in a back and forth arguing i don't
think that's respectful i don't think
that's a a good role model for our
children and while we're speaking about
role models
some of the behavior that's been
exhibited at board meetings i will tell
you right now
our kids are watching
and we're supposed to be the adults in
the room
so
no i would have to say i completely
refute that
thank you for the question
yes
are you referring to just this one item
on 3.02
okay and and thank you for that question
the reason i asked you to elaborate is
because i've been getting a lot of
questions where it's been rolled into
two different topics yes
i do take uh responsibility uh there
were some times where i feel that i
could have handled situations a little
bit better
um
we all make mistakes but that's not an
excuse so i would own my accountability
and accountability and accessibility are
two very important things to me in this
district
thank you for the question
tiffany i'm going to go to this
gentleman here first
hi jeremy how are you doing well um
jeremy i'm i'm going to ask you if you
could
shorten that
which is which is the bottom line
question
all right so
publicly uh trustee ford has already
released that she was the initial
requester and so uh there's a little bit
of confusion over majority uh votes you
know in our district and our meetings
you know it has to be four out of seven
so
for a special meeting or a special
agenda item that should be placed on the
agenda or a completely separate meeting
we have a redistricting special meeting
coming up you only need three trustees
so trustee ford was the initial
requester trustee guzman was the second
who concurred and i was the third in
response to your uh bottom line question
which i thank you for no i do not have
it out
for anyone
i
do not want to speak to anything having
to do with performance but i will i will
say that no i do not have it out for
anyone
i want to further add though that as i
put in my remarks when i see certain
things happening
we tell our kids if you see something
say something we have to follow that
ourselves and we have to be able to
stand up and be able to address the
issues that we see
thank you for the question
i'm so sorry jackie
when'd you see again
i didn't see you sorry go ahead
okay
i can always depend on you to just
get me there
um
the first part that you're asking about
i have to speak carefully on this i know
that you are extremely familiar with
open meeting law
yes an answer to your question which i
believe was was there an event that
precipitated this
i don't want to overstep boundaries in
speaking for trustee ford
but yes there was
a set
if you don't mind i'm going to call it a
set of circumstances maybe a domino
effect and so
that is the answer to your first
question
confidentiality measures prevent me from
going into any specifics
you know that really really depends on
how the discussion goes
i did put in one of my tweets and i know
that somebody here asked me about it i
had
stated
that
the item
3.02
that is on the agenda for my removal as
president
that it could possibly depending on how
the discussion goes it could precipitate
that other issues excuse me losing my
voice
other issues could possibly
lead to discussion
involving other trustees actions that's
the most careful way i can put it your
last question jackie i believe was
you want to go ahead and say it again
i have my opinions but because it is an
action item for tomorrow i am not
allowed to comment on that
i know you understand
thank you
there's somebody over here uh i think
it's tiffany and then dave
we have um with um
issues with their health trust we have
students who are late to class these are
the bus issues
and here we are again another meeting
where we're talking about issues about
the board going at it the
superintendent's contract um how can we
even insure for people in the community
staff members community members parents
that
their issues are even being addressed
while everyone is trying to focus on all
the issues with the superintendent and
their
thank you tiffany for the question first
of all we have to do better
we have to do better we we can't be
letting these distracting issues
take away from exactly what you were
talking about here which i already
mentioned in my general remarks i think
the public has been getting more
involved they've been writing in they
have
i don't want to say attacked us but
they've been very assertive on social
media and in
basically district our district emails
we need to find a way
that
what is not happening in our district
right now that should be happening
has to go forward and so that involves a
lot of these issues one thing that i'd
like to highlight if you don't mind for
your question
is what i mentioned as far as toxic
school climate and culture
so i have a lot of times people will say
trustee cavazos why are you talking
about this why you talk so much about
safety and mental health and what about
our achievement gap what about
you know what what's happening in our
schools you know as far as kids not
being able to know how to read or their
math scores are low
i look at the whole child again as a
former teacher and as a therapist
i get accused of oh all that warm and
fuzzy stuff guess what if we don't look
at that warm and fuzzy stuff if we don't
look as our children as whole they are
not just a data point on a computer
screen
there are whole children that have
issues so i think our community has to
demand more and i believe the board of
trustees and i'm going to refer to
dave's question too it's what it's going
to look like if we're not able to find a
way to come together on this
our decisions affect everyone
and we get a lot of questions about
what's operational what's uh oversight
and
you know
it's one of those things where
the excuses i think i put that on one of
my tweets it was like hashtag
color me tired of excuses i can't make
excuses anymore the whole board can't
make excuses anymore
we have to do better for our children i
think you had a second part
why did you choose to go with the third
option as having it in the
first of all i don't think that trustee
brooks or any other trustee or myself
included can just issue an ultimatum
such as i'm going to give you three
choices i think that right away just
even that vernacular even the way that
it's stated is not very collaborative
and so
being somebody that believes in
transparency and that we need to
actually get those facts out there
my immediate response was
we've already talked about some of these
things we've already discussed this
people have watched this for
hours
where it goes the conversation goes in a
circular fashion then it goes back and
then it does a u-turn i think they're
tired of that tiffany i think that
with me i looked at it and i just said
you know what
this is the time and this is the place
and some of this needs to come out in
public i don't want anybody to accuse me
of you're trying to broker a deal in a
back room because that already happens
way too much
so that's my that's my answer to that
did you have a follow
have dr up uh contract actually put in
the consent agenda rather than a special
item at the beginning of the meeting can
you just address if that's accurate or
not or if that's even possible if that
process is possible
okay let me get that straight that i was
trying to place it in the consent agenda
normally the consent agenda is put
together scheduled and compiled by the
superintendent and his staff
if you you know yourself that there's
all these different parts to the consent
agenda you know there's purchasing
there's things having to do with
transportation there's all different
categories there
this is the first i'm hearing of this
rumor and believe me i've heard a lot in
the last week but i have not even i've
not heard that one and my answer is no
there was never any effort on my part
you know i'm not
i'm not too i'm gonna address the second
part dave if you don't mind
i'm not too concerned about blowback
because what else can they do what else
can they do we've had when you've had
death threats when you've had to put in
an extra security system when you
already have a security system when you
have people
spreading untrue
[Music]
statements about you the blow back would
be the least of my problems
you've known me for a while you know
that i'm pretty thick-skinned
um
my kids like to say that you know i've
survived you know five children so you
know if you you know really i mean the
the goddess the the gold
the gray hairs they're there okay
but i'm not that would be the least of
my concerns
because
i think that you have to stand up for
when you see wrongs being done
and you're either going to stand up for
your morals and your ethics but if
you're
going to be someone that the last person
you talk to or special interest over
here affects you
then you're going to lose your way so
that's the second part
first part can you repeat it dave
what do you hope to achieve
one of the things i hope to achieve and
i'll just say this out you know
just openly is that
i'm hoping that we can tamp down some of
the concerns before tomorrow's meeting
it may get the opposite effect it may be
riles people up more if that's what it
does so be it
i would have to say my main
goal tonight
is transparency
and getting this out in the open
because there are so many folks and i
hear from them constantly like how come
we didn't know about this and how come
you guys are talking about this and you
know what did you decide in a back room
or a closed session and we're not
allowed you know by law we cannot
discuss or divulge anything that's in a
closed session so what i'm hoping to
accomplish is that somewhere our
colleagues can come together
and we can figure out that path forward
because as i said at the end of my
remarks our kids are depending on us i
mean what is the main concern
if you are on the board of trustees as a
former teacher i have to tell you it's
our children their physical
academic mental and emotional welfare if
our children are not okay then you know
what we need to be out of a job
we're not doing our job if they're not
okay
thank you dave for the question
yes
[Music]
good question and i'm sorry i didn't
catch your name
thank you i remember talking with you we
kind of had a little back and forth
texting thing going there
first of all i do want to clarify that
my job is not at stake it's just the
title the position and just to let you
know that unlike trustee brooks and
trustee wright that came right before me
i have never intended i made it quite
clear that i was not going to try to get
a second consecutive term as president
so it's not my job it's just
you know what i really have left let's
see this is what the end of october i
have two months left like 60 days the
very first work session
in january is when we elect a new slate
of officers so anyway i wanted to
clarify that because people were asking
me are you going to be removed from the
board i said they're still stuck with me
for at least another year
the other question i think is more
important kim and that's the one that
you asked about parents almost the same
as what i answered tiffany and that's
that this is again
a very very
deep
lack of communication because we only
have one employee
all the other employees the teachers the
support professionals they are all under
the oversight of the superintendent the
superintendent
is our only employee
so again this i would have to go back to
my mantra of finding a path forward
and there has to be a way that the board
of trustees and the superintendent can
collaboratively work together as a team
that's what i would want to tell parents
and i'm just going to throw in we have
to do better
yes
i didn't hear the very last part i can't
hear you very well
well first of all i should have taken
that picture of my office for the fact
that said president you know i should
have done that to begin with i think i
might have one around somewhere
it sounds like you're asking me like
what would i see as my legacy for this
year this 10 months or whatever
in this position
not like the other three years
first of all i am
proud to say that i am one of a limited
number of districts
across the whole united states that was
able to get a safe storage
i guess you would call i think our
formal name was safe storage firearm
resolution that went out to over 300 000
homes i'm sure you guys are are
cognizant that
we did have a lot of publicity
about suicides
some of those suicides and again i
cannot quote confidential details
but more one is too many all right but
we had several
that
were carried out with firearms that were
left
unsecured in the home
so that's one thing
the other thing is that
during this tenure with all of this
going on
and the pandemic i want to say that
we've shown a laser-like focus on the
inequities in some of i don't want to
just say our zip codes but
all of these things mental health the
suicide rate
the digital divide these aren't new i'm
old i've been around for a while so
these were already here before but the
pandemic forced us to shine that light
so we could say how come these kids have
this but these kids don't
what's happening over here with our ell
program what's happening over here with
our special needs kids and again what's
happening with the educators
that we are entrusting our children to
for several hours a day if we're not
taking care of them then how are they
going to take care of our kids
so
those are a couple of things i could you
know i could be on the soapbox and you'd
be stuck here for a while